estos viñedos del sureste de francia
cultiva en la apreciada variedad de uva
púlsar es una planta frágil demasiado
sol puede marchitar la fruta
aquí se puede ver que estas uvas han
sido abrazadas por el sol y el calor
será lo que es lo que las marchita
cuando están así se arruinan sin grado
con soft adif y se va a perder alrededor
del 20 por ciento de la cosecha de este
año y va a ser más difícil recoger lo
que queda vamos a tener que retirar
todas las uvas secas una por una para
que no afecten el sabor en las barricas
de vino en algunas zonas las pérdidas
llegan al 60% en esta región suelen ser
los inviernos duros los que afectan la
cosecha pero ahora el verano también es
una temporada de alto riesgo sobre este
futuro esperable a mitad año hasta ahora
el sol era amigo de los viñedos no
estamos acostumbrados a que el problema
sean las temperaturas demasiado altas
los periodos de sequía son ahora mucho
más fuertes que antes estamos
preocupados los viticultores esperan
desesperadamente que llueva antes de la
vendimia a finales de agosto